للحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا انعكاسات
وارتدادات ليس على الاطراف المتحاربه فقط
وانما على الدول المتضمنه وداعمه عسكريا
وسياسيا بعد تاثيرات الحرب هنا في برلين
فبعد استقاله وزيره الدفاع السابقه
كريستيانو لامبرخت لم تتاخر السلطاته في
الافصاح عن اسم خليفه
الذي يبلغ من العمر 62 عاما ويشغل منصب
وزير الداخليه في ولايه ساكسونيا السفلى
منذ عام 2013
تتصاعد الضغوط على برلين من الحلفاء
الغربيين للسماح لاوكرانيا باستخدام
دبابات المانيه الصنع وهذا قبل مؤتمر يوم
الجمعه في القاعده العسكريه الامريكيه في
رمشتاين حول الخطط الغربيه لتزويد اكيف
بمزيد من الاسلحه يصف المستشار الالماني
الجديد بانه صديق وسياسي جيد
لقد طلبت من باريس بيستوريا سيصبح وزيرا
للدفاع العلمانيين انه ليس مجرد صديق
وسياسي جيد فحسب ولكنه يملك خبره كبيره في
القضايا سياسيه والامنيه
حتى الان كما يبدو بخصوص الموافقه على
ارسال دبابات اليو بارد ثقيله الى
اوكرانيا بسبب مخاوف من ان تعتبر هذه
الخطوه تسعيدا للحرب وتحتاج دول اخرى
لديها مثل هذه الدبابات ايضا موافقه برلين
قبل نقلها الى دوله معينه